why did it get physical that day though
I'm still not understanding why they get
physical because when she stood up she
was talking to Buck you know what I mean
don't get up and start bucking at me say
you would hit me like what you mean I
did not tell you that that I would hit
you I yes you did you kept draining me
well guess what well get out of my face
then girl who do the first punch that
day it wasn't no punches because she was
doing too much so yeah I choked her a
little bit yeah get down sit down so
this is what I call the ghetto mom the
ghetto mom the abusive mom um she's
constantly not apologizing for anything
she's constantly blaming her daughter
and she doesn't act like a mother that
actually loves her daughter